analysis of mitochondrial DNA reveals
that a resourceful 53 hundred year old
ice man or a sheepskin loincloth cow
leather shoelaces goat hide leggings
sheep and goat mixed coat and a brown
bear hat meanwhile researchers at
Stanford developed a new fabric that
unlike cotton allows infrared radiation
to pass through it so you'll feel 4
degrees cooler if you're wearing plastic
clothes Vsauce come in here this is Mon
Flo
[Music]
Duo skin makes your arm and interface
developed by the MIT Media Lab a cheap
skin safe gold leaf material is attached
in various designs to the skin the three
interfaces include wireless
communication touch sensing input and
displaying output metallic temporary
tattoos can control mobile devices like
a trackpad and also data like movie
tickets could be embedded in the
material they believe on skin
electronics will become less taboo over
time and develop into user friendly body
decoration in science fiction becoming
reality news an astronaut sequenced DNA
in space while aboard the International
Space Station a biomolecule sequencer
was used to identify the DNA sequence of
a mouse virus and bacteria while
identical samples were sequenced at the
same time on earth to control for
differences in results current practical
applications include being able to test
the fungi growing on the ISS without
having to send a sample back to earth
and future amazing applications include
detecting life on Mars virtual reality
brain control and a robotic exoskeleton
combined to retrain people to walk the
system allows patients with spinal cord
injuries to regain voluntary leg muscle
movement and to feel touch and pain in
their paralyzed limbs after 12 months of
training which involves patients
imagining walking through a virtual
scene the EEG picked up signals for the
lower limbs that had been previously
lost the patients wore sleeves with
haptic feedback to react to each step
and even varied so walking on sand would
feel different than walking on grass
eventually they could walk into real
world with robotic training devices and
the research is ongoing the oldest
fossils ever found are 3.7 billion years
old
Australian geologists discovered a newly
exposed outcrop of sedimentary rocks and
minerals in Greenland that was
previously covered in snow they found
evidence of fossilized microbial mats
called stromatolites which are shallow
water microorganism communities due to
the complexity of stromatolites they
believe life may have started much
earlier than when they appear in the
fossil
record and this discovery increases
interest in life on other planets there
is now a drone that drops ignition
spheres to start fires the unmanned
aerial system for firefighting was
created to safely perform prescribed
fires that are used to combat the spread
of wildfires and benefit ecosystems by
fighting off invasive species
traditionally helicopter based ignition
has been used but it's expensive and
dangerous so this new system represents
a major upgrade in fire EPFL built a
robotic foosball table a camera under
the table tracks the ball and linear and
rotational motors control the players
the robot can already beat humans the
robot knows where the human player is
positioned and can react accordingly and
now they're working on having a robot
play against another robot 3d printing
now enters 4d engineers are printing
shape-changing polymers that remember
their original shape when heated to
specific temperatures they believe what
they call 4d printing could be used for
biomedical devices like medicine that's
released when the patient has a fever or
used for solar cells that move in
relation to temperature to optimize
performance really I just think this
little soft polymer claw thing looks
cool so yeah finally DFK eye at germany
unveiled a project to search for
extraterrestrial life in the deep oceans
of Jupiter's moon Europa
[Music]
you
I'm gonna leave you with a virtual
reality robot arm and as always thanks
for watching you are about to take a
journey out of this world into the world
of the future forget the world around
you forget the people around you you are
entering Futurama it's hard to believe
there actually is an oven that can cook
a roast in minutes by electronics then
bake you potatoes in less time than it
takes to carve the roast a refrigerated
cart ready for wheeling into a game room
or out onto the patio perfect for
keeping foods and drinks cool for
informal entertaining yes that's a
wonderful idea
and I'll bet this washer will get
anything clean even my most delicate
things he's not fine
I sure did everything I saw is out of
this world
there's a brand-new episode of loot over
on dong so click here to check that out
and while we're working on the second
box curiosity box number one is almost
sold out so if you're the type of person
that's got to catch them all make sure
you subscribe to the curiosity box today
just go to curiosity box calm there's
also a link at the top of this video's
description so you could clip that yeah